San Diego born Tijuana raised 15 seasons
15 seasons in Major League Baseball the
number one overall pick of the 2005 time
MLB all-star four time Gold Glove Award
winner two times Silver Slugger Award
winner for time member of Team Mexico he
is Adrian Gonzalez good to see you sir
thank you good to see ya and I left out
being a dad no husband a family man that
I have seen personally yeah that's my
biggest accomplishment there being a
good dad Chris I have learned from this
man I've learned from this man watching
watching you be a parent on on a
sideline you're very encouraging you're
not you know one of those helicopter
dads encouraged I've seen it I've seen
that our daughters play soccer together
and perform together and it's been great
getting to meet you and uh my wife Betsy
through it Susie and I have just enjoyed
getting to know you over the last few
years so it's a pleasure having you here
thank you yeah thank you for having me
so let's get into the news of the day
man did you think you'd ever see a
pitcher make a 324 million dollars over
nine years Adrian it was trending that
way and then after the last couple of
years I didn't think so and now you know
what do you what do you mean by that
well you know the last couple of years
it was like anybody ever 29 they
wouldn't give any long-term deal to so
maybe a 25 year old but 29 year old you
know that's something that uh what
definitely didn't see coming but you
know good good for Gary good for
baseball
so I guess necessity might be the mother
of invention but why do you think we're
seeing now a change in attitude well I
do think that there's been a lot of
things that have really ticked off some
some of the players or the
representatives or you know we talked
about agents and the CBA and all that
and I think the revenue for baseball is
there and you know you're making the
money put it back into it put it back
into the sport so okay let me let me
unpack this a little bit so the last
couple of years has been something that
players have taken issue with I think
the Association has made a few mentions
on
why players are taking so long to sign
you know going into spring training and
all that and I think this year they made
a point to to start the bidding and
submit offers a little bit earlier so
what happened last year with Keuchel say
yeah we're he's he's at home exactly
through pretty much to June right
crystal in Atlanta finally took him off
his couch yeah and Kimbrel yeah I
believe so Ryan Bo went to the Cubs yeah
so the fact that we're seeing signings
now before the year is out is a response
to to what yeah I think it's the agents
you know getting on top of it and saying
I'm gonna take over the offers now and
I'm not gonna let this guy sit out of
fear for for what I'm here everybody
kind of dragging it I think so for
everybody kind of dragging it and and I
think the owners and and and the
Commissioner everybody got together and
they said let's let's kind of get
something going in the winter meeting so
we can make a splash and keep baseball
in the news you know what I I love it
yeah you know because and that that's
the thing that I was mentioning last
year is that right now right now college
football is kind of you know winding
down if we just got we just got the big
explosion of who's gonna be playing in
the college of the play we got the bowl
game set the Heisman Trophy is coming up
in football there's three more
regular-season weeks left yeah this is a
perfect time for baseball to have a free
agent frenzy exactly and then stay in
stay in the news and and just continue
to be present you know within the fence
do they have to reach out to Boris and
say you got to play ball on that front
too because Scott's a guy he's already
in conversations what do you mean I mean
I you know you have you have the big
agents that definitely have a lot of
saying what goes on so yeah Adrian
Gonzalez here on the Rich Eisen show
what do you think of the style of play
that baseball has suddenly settled into
where it seems to be a walk a strikeout
or a homerun about what would you say 50
percent of the time yeah even though I
might be
what do you think about that Adrian I
really like the old-school baseball
better hidden runs button guys overall
that the strategy part of it I think
there's there's there's more to baseball
the fans can be a little more engaged
and think about who should bind the
conversation with in baseball you know
it's more it keeps the fans engaged the
other way this one you know you just sit
back and wait for the homerun if you
don't see a homerun there's really no
action with a strikeout in the walk so I
think that's the main reason why if
attendance and and viewership has gone
down is because of that but on the front
office side there's there's a science to
that so I'm not a big fan of it I like
to see managers like Bruce Bochy and you
know the old-school managers that would
put bunts and hen runs and all that
stuff to get things going who is the
manager you had that flu most by the
seat of his pants I mean my favorite
manager of all time was Bruce Bochy for
sure why is that I just the way he the
way he communicated the way he you know
stuck by his word everything he said it
was and he was just you know the
smartest guy there he's a hall-of-famer
right absolutely that's it I mean is you
don't even stutter yeah he's a 100% Hall
of Fame yeah Major League Baseball
Cooperstown candidate you sure yeah and
was he your first manager was who who's
your first no my first manager was Buck
Showalter
there on in Texas right in Texas okay
where were you when you were picked
first overall what was your draft day
like actually they flew me out to Miami
pre pre draft okay
they had told me that I was gonna be the
first pick we had agreed to to the deal
about a few days before and so we flew
out to Miami and I was in in the
conference room where they where they do
the draft okay yeah and so just like we
would not normally see an NFL player
that's what you got a little bit yeah I
got to take batting practice with the
team that same day and when the Rangers
would know know what the Marlins see
where you were drafted by the mama the
Marlins yeah yeah so I was in Miami in
the middle of the summer so how did you
wind up okay so you started with the
Marlins a in the minor leagues yeah and
the minor leagues and then you I got
traded I got traded the year that the
the Marlins won they needed a closer at
the time and they went out and got okay
or being at the trade deadline
yeah not who get Urbina yeah I have not
heard in a very long time yeah I was
that prospect that was uh or the
prospect was a prosper they got traded
at the time yeah so they could get the
closer they needed to win the World
Series so you were a factor in the Miami
Marlins the Florida Marlins at the time
winning the World Series huh and tell me
the craziest story you're comfortable
sharing from the Red Sox craziest story
comfortable sharing from your two two
years with the Boston Red Sox craziest
story we had we had we had some some fun
times on the plane you know I think
there was some fun stories there that uh
you know just a lot of gambling going on
that made it made it made it interesting
poppy was the one who was there was
there was a lot of guys that uh that
would get into the games Varitek poppy
Papelbon yeah there was there was some
there was some fun games going on in the
on the plane a little a little too far
out of my league no kid yeah and you
were enjoy the card game but when the
when the stakes get really high I like I
like to step away you tapped out yeah
okay yeah you went to the first class
see younger no I just stepped away and
and and then wouldn't uh wouldn't call
any of those big they called the big
bets they need how to get me out of the
game okay Adrian Gonzalez twofold yeah
okay and then coming here to the Los
Angeles Dodgers
what was that like for you obviously
being back in Southern California yeah I
mean surprise trade definitely wasn't
expected but when I heard it was the
Dodgers I was really happy because you
know like you said coming back to
Southern California being close to the
family again and being close to home and
actually ended up turning into my home
which is how much I loved it here so it
was just it was it was it was if I
didn't want to get traded but if I was
gonna get traded it was a perfect spot
okay do you want to ask him the poll
question I'm gonna turn you into a
member of the media for a quick second
okay okay as the poll question Adrian
Gonzalez Chris Brockman go for it
alright agent based on
negative this is a negative question I'm
gonna you're very positive gentlemen
you've got nothing but positivity that
oozes out of you it just it just comes
out of your pores I'm gonna give you
just a quick heads-up that he's a Boston
guy so that makes me very miserable deep
inside yes I'm only happy when I'm
saying you're only happy when you're
upset and sad and booing Tom Brady at
half time despite six championships in
the case I wasn't at the game you okay
I'm sorry I'm gonna stop setting it up
go and ask the poll question of Adrian
Gonzalez Chris okay which team based on
Gerrit Cole signing which team will most
regret this big contract that they
handed out the Phillies to Bryce Harper
the Padres to Manny Machado the
Nationals to Stephen Strasburg were the
Yankees to Gerrit Cole who's gonna
regret it the most if you had to choose
one I would have to say the Phillies
with Bryce not because Bryce isn't gonna
perform but I don't think having Bryce
there guarantees a World Series why do
you say that because Philly's a small
ballpark you can get most hitters it
could I can perform there and for me
money's better spent on pitchers in the
playoffs and hitters no kidding yeah why
is that his pitchers dominate in the
playoffs you know you've seen it you
always have those those performances
that when that take you to the World
Series you have Bumgarner do it just you
know you've had Strasburg and Scherzer
do it this year the time before that you
see I mean you just see it every year
that I mention performance you can even
go back to Randy Johnson and Schilling
with the Diamondbacks exactly so
pitching ones in the playoffs hitting
doesn't sawfish pitcher you had a face
was who I always say in his prime Tim
Lincecum he was nasty
why cuz the way he delivered yeah he
just teaches like to run that fast
fastball inside and he threw the change
at Brit right off of him most Pitts most
right-handed pitchers to the changeup
away he we used to throw it inside and
it just drove me crazy him Lynch down I
would not have guessed I mean I mean
forget for a little guy
I mean my childhood hero growing up one
of them was Ron Guidry who was not a big
dude he was a slight Louisiana Lightning
and the ball would just explode out of
his
and and Lincecum was you know obviously
maybe a similar right there was a lot of
body his mechanics it was hard to pick
up the bottom out of his hand and it
just looked like it was gonna hit you
and ran back to the corner and then
you're like okay I'm gonna swing this
time and the bottom dropped out and then
before you going to get to everything
that that's going on with you as well
Bumgarner with the Dodgers I mean do you
think that that it's it's crazy I don't
see it happening I mean if the Giants
offer anything close I think he stays
with the Giants rather than going to
rival Dodgers you know but never no
money speaks so got to say if you're a
left-handed if the Bumgarner comes to
the Dodgers in a three-game set is Ryu
Kershaw Bumgarner as a left-handed
hitter do you even bring your bat to the
stadium well that's the thing the way
that baseball is now their problem
probably only gonna think we're gonna go
five innings so I have to you know third
time through the order exactly it's nuts
that's the sort of stuff that's decided
before the game right I mean for me
seeing like David Freese lead off you
know that I don't get it so you can get
that second at-bat all right so let's go
through this year I have right here a
nice six of calidad beer yeah this is
your beer is this yeah okay caddy that
beer Mexican style lager brewed in Santa
Barbara approved in Santa Barbara
California okay so you get water you do
you enjoy a beer every now and then I do
okay I do I had one last night yeah we
all we've only shared red wine before so
maybe I gotta try one of these babies as
well yes this is for me and it's nice
and chilled right now as well did we
keep this in an inner fridge I brought
it from a fridge so yeah okay you have a
cooler in your car pretty much no but a
far Drive okay okay and it's distributed
right here in Southern California and
you are you I know you guys are
genuinely excited about this you got a
Jersey Mike's franchise right here yeah
how many Jersey Mike's do you have we we
have eleven at the moment two in
construction and taking them into Mexico
which is fine that's gonna be amazing
okay why do you why do you
and you're not just a guy who just
spends the money and that you are all
over this you're involved in the I mean
flowchart big-time right I'm there I
mean obviously I'm not doing the
day-to-day operations because our stores
are in San Diego and Palm Springs right
but you know the weekly calls the emails
taking make sure the numbers all look
right yeah okay and then active faith
sports that's a clothing line what is
that Christian clothing apparel line
that I was started by an ex-basketball
player that blew out his knees rookie
season Lanny Smith
Steph Curry's a partner in it Vernon
Vernon Wells is a partner in it so a lot
of athletes in it and you how did you
get involved through Lanny you met him
met him in baseball he was distributing
a bunch of years ago when he first
started distributing these wristbands
that a lot of the guys you'll see a lot
of the guys we're all over that says and
Jesus name I play mm-hm and just met him
through that and just always continue
the conversation with him and yeah and
what's pop fly XP that you were chairman
Huff likes Pisa is a digital brand
branding app company that we developed
where we basically do free apps for a
sleet's
well my elbow following anybody has a
following that create an app and able to
monetize their social media currency
through and then you were to digital
brand again that you are the chairman of
that and then there's the Adrian and
Betsey Gonzalez foundation that we
talked about earlier as well everybody
follow this man on Twitter and Instagram
at a dream underscore l Titan last
question for you the most beautiful
rendition of let it go that you've ever
heard was performed by who by your
daughter by Taylor absolutely Taylor
nailed it I'll take that I will
absolutely take that hey man thanks for
coming on here and he's a blast but skip
doing it you know you're very
opinionated what comes to the baseball
world and I'd love to have you back here
as a voice on this front as much as
early so much and I'm not just saying
that cuz you bring beer well ok very
good
you bring the called-- beer with you
thanks for coming on man thank you
that's the best your whole family thank
you Adrian Gonzalez here on the Rich
Eisen show for more of the Rich Eisen
show to
- audience channel 239 on DirecTV for
free on BR live or download the Rich
Eisen show app